skittish been a little longer than I've
intended since the last time I did an
episode of animation junk ebook kung fu
panda 3 is out so let's talk about that
now unfortunately haven't gotten around
to talking about any of the other Kung
Fu Panda movies in this series up at
this point and I had intended to do so
the first one in particular is really
just a such a comfort food movie for me
I love its pacing I love its characters
I love its action I love the music it
just gives me a warm feeling inside the
second one is also quite good although I
have to admit I haven't seen it again
since he came out in theaters but before
even going into this one I had a sinking
feeling I was getting a shrek three vibe
off that and since I haven't covered the
strike series on those either i'll
explain that briefly basically i think
the first two Shrek movies actually are
quite good and hold up quite well the
third one has a whole lot of problems
but chief among them is the fact that
they made the decision that Shrek cannot
change and evolve so he kept having to
get reset back to the same grumpy over
that we knew in the first Shrek but by
the third time he was so contrived the
reason that they had to have just have
him be all grumpy in any evolution as
character he had just gets completely
undone I was getting that vibe off the
trailers for the seeing that PO is going
to have to teach kung fu to people in
that he was not a very good teacher it
struck me as just this contrived recent
to have PO be stumbling and confused and
not that great at what he's doing which
just sets him back to where he was in
the first one again now unfortunately
that is kind of what happens to a
certain extent but this is really a case
where the film starts out in a bit of a
wonky place the middle is it moves
things along but it's nothing
particularly memorable but it builds to
a really good climax the third act of
this movie really does save the whole
thing we get great fun inventive action
it pays off everything that's been going
on up to that point really well on
multiple levels and I also really love
most of the messages that are at the
heart of this one there's a whole lot of
emphasis on self exploration and knowing
yourself which is actually kind of an
unusual lesson to have
in a kid's movie because by and large
it's an adult question you know who am i
what is the essential essence of me I
saw something you'd expect to be tackled
in a kid's movie but they tackle it in a
way that not only works but i think is
really gonna be quite accessible to kids
jack black as always is this movie he
does fantastic voice work he brings that
same level of energy and fun that makes
po the character that you just love to
see because even when he's stumbling and
isn't quite sure what he's doing he just
he's got such gusto I never get tired of
Po and as always he does completely
steal the thunder of anyone else on the
screen so the rest of the voices are
fine that includes the new blood we get
JK Simmons as a new villain who is an
interesting villain and you know he does
find we got Bryan Cranston as pose
father and they're both fine neither of
them are particularly exceptional but I
don't think that's necessary much just
just because really everybody lives in
pose shadow in this series that's kind
of a reality of it the fights are I
don't want to say they're not as good
but it takes longer for us to start
getting the really good action
set-pieces normally they've got them
sprinkled across the movie this time the
earlier ones they're okay they're fine
but again it's it's the third act it's
the climax portion that really gives us
the goods that's where the whole thing
comes together that's where it delivers
on the levels you want a kung fu panda
movie to deliver on and like I said in
terms of core message of the things I
gotta give props to what the message is
and how it's delivered this is still
probably going to write as my least
favorite entry in the Kung Fu Panda
series just because it is so back loaded
all the good stuff is in the climax and
everything up to that point is getting
us there but is it gonna be worth the
trip well it was but the trip was not
the most important part once we got to
the destination yeah it this thing took
off of course that's me viewing it as an
adult I took my child to it she had a
great time right from the beginning
because there's plenty of slapstick and
fun and people get knocked around and no
small kid is gonna be bored by this so
it's only my adult critical mind that's
picking apart the first two-thirds in
this movie for a kid they're probably
gonna love the whole thing that's just
me have you seen kung fu panda 3
what were your thoughts on it whatever
they were drop something down in the
comments and let's talk about it please
go ahead like subscribe check out the
council of geeks podcast on stitcher and
itunes and as for me i will be back as
soon as i can get my next fix